(audience applauding)
(audience laughing)
- Damn, no wonder Richard
Williams was so stressed.
His junk was squished.
Where's Regina, what?
Regine, what the hell?
You, you were supposed to be Venus.
- I know, I am Venus, as Tammy Faye.
(audience laughing)
I'm sorry, all right?
I'm just Tammy Faye.
I always wanted to play
a crazy white lady.
(audience laughing)
Hi, guys.
- [Wanda] Well, where's Amy?
Amy's supposed to be Serena.
- [Amy] I'm right here!
- [Wanda] Wait, what the hell?
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
What are you doing?
This was not the plan.
- Well, we're supposed to dress up
as our favorite movie, right?
- All right.
You know what?
No, that's not what we were doing.
You know what, I've had it with y'all.
I'm, I'm through.
You know what?
I shaved a lot!
Like a lot.
- [Regina] What, wait,
we're sorry, Daddy, please!
- Okay, yeah, okay, I do
not know how to get down,
so if somebody could maybe come.